since his big screen debut in 2002 we've
seen a lot of Spiderman he's appeared in
his own movies and become a major part
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe though
his fate there is to be determined each
installment of spider-man has its ups
and downs with into the spider-verse
making a splash it'll be the fourth film
iteration of the web slinging hero all
within the last couple decades but which
spider-man is truly king in order to
determine the best cinematic Spidey
there's a few categories to look at
let's start with the actors who've
played the Super Hero Tobey Maguire was
the first spider-man so he's always
going to cast a big shadow Maguire was
27 years old when the first spider-man
movie came out in 2002 that's a bit old
to be playing a high schooler
but Maguire still looked like Peter
Parker come to life and he fit in very
well with many of directors Sam Raimi's
comedic flourishes Maguire delivers all
of spider-man's signature quips well and
can even pull off some impeccable
slapstick humor
[Music]
Andrew Garfield was cast following his
breakthrough role in the social network
like McGuire door filled was a bit older
but he keeps spider-man a little bit of
a darker edge in many ways
Garfield's version is cooler than
McGuire's version
Garfield captured the term nerd in a
more modern sense where it's not just
associated with being bullied this Peter
Parker even skateboards Garfield was 29
years old when the amazing spider-man
came out which is even older than
McGuire was when the first Spiderman was
released yet the heavy dose of teen
angst he added to the character made him
seem younger unfortunately he didn't
have the goofy innocence Maguire had
which is a huge part of what makes Peter
Parker Peter Parker Tom Holland first
popped up in Captain America Civil War
first seen stealing performance hey
everyone he then got his own platform in
homecoming in 2017 Holland's performance
brought a new energy to the character
not to mention he had the part at age 20
which made him the youngest actor to get
the role for once the character actually
felt like a high schooler as an added
bonus Pollan gave Peter a bit of a New
York accent Garfield did too but this
one feels the most like he's just a kid
from Queens Thank You mr. stark
I'm good Shameka more voices Miles
Morales a character who first put on the
spider-man mask an ultimate fallout
number four in 2011 since then
Morales has become a fan favorite and
fans have been begging for a movie for
years is it fair to judge Myles versus
the other versions of spider-man with
Peter Parker under the mask I say why
not though we only have a voice
performance to go off of more ends up
being a great choice he proves to be an
incredibly convincing high schooler
how many much body people are there next
let's talk about the movies themselves
there were a lot of things outside the
fight scenes that gave the original
trilogy an added dose of drama and say
what you will about the third movie but
the trilogy works together to build a
fascinating portrait of a character
split between power and responsibility
this great power comes great
responsibility
in the first movie Peter Parker's
unrequited love for Mary Jane is a big
highlight the tension of MJ liking
spider-man who can forget that
upside-down kiss while being just
friends with Peter added a special sense
of intrigue outside of the main action
in the second movie Peter looks like a
bad friend and nephew every time he has
to run out to be the hero he bears the
burden of being spider-man all alone
spider-man in spider-man 2 were at the
core about Peter Parker learning to
balance standing for justice and his
commitments to those he cared about in
his life by the end of the second movie
Mary Jane knows that Peter is spider-man
but in the third movie that knowledge
becomes a problem
Peter recreates that famous case with
Gwen Stacy and now Mary Jane clearly
sees the moments that Peter chooses hero
work over her which pushes her briefly
into the arms of Peters one-time best
friend Harry Osborn Harry is interesting
because like Mary Jane he learns about
Peters alter-ego but it causes him to
hate his old friend because spider-man
killed his father though spider-man 3 is
connected to the other two on a
character level overall it goes pretty
off the rails emo Spidey was a choice
and overall it just has too much going
on which will become a problem in the
next spider-man reboot
Garfield's movies have less of a
connecting thread the films work best
when they're taking a different
direction than the earlier trilogy but
ultimately it's too similar for a new
series with hardly any time separating
it from the earlier version this version
rehashes Uncle Ben's death Peter faces
off against the same bully at school
Harry's his best friend who turns into a
villain and he's pretty much battling
the same problems and demons but like I
said when it's different it's better in
this version Gwen Stacy who doesn't show
up until spider-man 3 in the first
version is Peters love interest Garfield
and Emma Stone have solid chemistry
another part that worked was giving more
of Peters early backstory by introducing
us to his parents but the filmmakers
were never able to shake off the
decision to retell spider-man's origin
story and didn't do enough to
differentiate Garfield spider-man while
McGuire's was still fresh in our minds
homecoming was smart and that it decide
to skip over spider-man's origin story
which we already seen twice on the big
screen it went right into where his
story left off following the events in
Germany from Civil War at the end of the
day everything about homecoming is fresh
he's a brand new love interest a new
funny best friend who's not named Harry
MJ comes as a surprise towards the end
of the movie and even his high school
bully flash is completely reimagined are
you really friends with Peter Parker the
biggest change was adding Tony Stark aka
Iron Man to this story giving Peter a
new and interesting father figure in
lieu of Uncle Ben Tony Stark might have
a reputation for being reckless but he
turns out to be very good at giving
teenage Peter Parker a few stern
lectures
and forbidding his access to a high-tech
suit oh this eventually led to the
biggest emotional payoff of infinity war
I don't feel so good
you're right I don't know I don't know
what's happening into the spider-verse
might be the most ambitious spider-man
movie yet bringing us into multiple
universes in ways that are mind-bending
fun and funny miles doesn't appear to
get pushed around by bullies as much as
some of the other previous iterations
were his struggles deal with adapting
and fitting into his tough new school
while navigating a relationship with his
tough but loving cop father was a
complicated relationship with spider-man
himself spider-man swings in once a day
zip zap zop in his little mask and
answers to no me
miles spider-man origin story is
slightly different from the others and
it feels much more streamlined after
three iterations of Peter Parker it's
nice to see a completely new character
taking on the mantle breathing fresh
life into the beloved comic book
character one thing of note miles is
afro-latino which was always a big part
of his story since his introduction in
the comics when stacy is back here once
again but this time she gets to take a
stab at being a superhero
yet another of this movie's very
refreshing twist and in this movie Peter
Parker is washed up but he ultimately
assumes an Uncle Ben role as a mentor to
Miles it's a very different spider-man
than we're used to seeing in fact Myles
has many role models to choose from
between Peter his father and his uncle
Aaron a hero is only as good as the
villains they have to fight Tobey
Maguire's spider-man faced off against
some all-time great villains in the
first movie will Dafoe played Green
Goblin he was a terrifying presence as a
man at war within himself and as a kid
first watching this movie I'm not gonna
lie I kind of wanted that glider in the
second movie Alfred Molina played dr.
octopus maybe one of the coolest looking
villains of all time like Green Goblin
his origin story was built on loss and
lack of control there was something both
tragic and compelling about his
backstory both villains were played by
world-class actors and most
interestingly both villains are people
from Peter Parker's life which
complicated things when it came to fight
spider-man 3 however suffered from too
many villains it was an interesting
choice that Peter was overtaken by the
alien symbiote slime turning the hero
into a bit of a villain himself but
anything rewarding about that got lost
in the fray between all the other bad
guys like Eddie Brock's venom Sandman
and Harry Osborn version of the Goblin
the amazing spider-man 2 had Spidey
facing off against the lizard played by
Rhys Ifans yet another scientist whose
work went to his head it was fine but
felt a little familiar by that point the
amazing spider-man 2 gave spider-man too
many villains to fight against at once
this was a major part of its downfall
it's hard to pick what was worse the
laughably bad CGI of electro or the
Rhino which was thrown in for absolutely
no reason at the end of the second
amazing movie as a cliffhanger for a
sequel that never came the most
compelling villain might have been Harry
Osborn's goblin but we only got a little
peek at him towards the end boom coming
bounce back pitting spider-man against
the vulture played by Michael Keaton who
also has another iconic superhero role
under his belt
she gives a great performance and the
added twist that he plays Peter's love
interest father was unexpected
when homecoming did really well was
played of fan boys and girls in a very
subtle way now you're the shoulder we
see another Spiderman villain shocker
wearing sleeves reminiscent of the comic
book version of the character it's a
nice nod to a comic book villain without
overwhelming us with too many bad guys
to keep track of and Miles Morales faces
off against kingpin you probably
recognize kingpin from the daredevil
movie and TV series he's been played by
Michael Clarke Duncan and Vincent
D'Onofrio now
he's voiced by Liam Schreiber he's not
always about the money spider-man who
knew that one villain could cost so much
higher for so many Marvel heroes
movie adaptations should be allowed some
creative freedom but it's always an
added bonus when they take loyal fans
into consideration McGuire's movies made
one big change spider-man's web shooters
come with all his new spider powers in
the comic spider-man designs the webs
himself this might seem like a minor
detail but with organic webs we get less
of a glimpse into the characters
intellect and inventiveness this one
difference has caused an uproar even to
this day the green Goblin's look was
also modernised but that was probably
for the best the goblins purple outfit
probably wouldn't have translated well
in cinemas still some of the movie
scenes like the wrestling scene and his
confrontation with Uncle Ben's killer
were like shop by shop remakes of Stan
Lee's early comics the amazing movies
gave spider-man his homemade web
shooters back and with that a great
wrong felt righted director Marc Webb
said that he met with Stan Lee while
developing the film and discussed how
the homemade web shooters served to
dramatize Peters intellect many other
major moments from the comics were there
like Gwen Stacy's tragic death which
happened in a very similar fashion in
the movie even the green coke Glenn
wears in the movie matches her coat from
hanauma crook death and as we mentioned
the amazing movies had an issue with its
villains
however Green Goblin and amazing
spider-man 2 portrayed by Dane DeHaan
looks at least a little bit more similar
to the Green Goblin portrayed in some
versions of the comics homecoming takes
tech to a whole other level spider-man
has an internet powered suit that is
partially controlled by Tony Stark that
suit isn't just mental one up Holland's
big screen spider-man predecessors but
rather it's directly taken from the
Civil War comic book series there are
little ways that homecoming connected
itself to the larger spider-man universe
donald glover pops up as a criminal
named aaron davis in one scene he
references his nephew Miles Morales
who we get to know better and into the
spider-verse glover voice morales in the
ultimate spider-man TV series and an
unsuccessful 2010 twitter campaign to
get tall clever cast as spider-man
famously went viral
my name is Miles Morales I'm spike into
the spider-verse
is partially based off of spider-verse a
2014 comic book storyline it's also
inspired by spider-man's indelible mark
on pop culture history the screenwriting
team did their best to remain faithful
to the source material but they couldn't
get in every single alternative version
of spider-man into the film yes
spider-ham is a real Marvel Comics
character as our Spider Man new AR and
Penny Parker but into the spider verse
is also faithful to the movies making
very clear from the start that it's
connected to the Tobey Maguire trilogy
through a groundbreaking combination of
CGI and hand-drawn animation into the
spider verse looks like a comic book in
motion producers Phil Lord and Chris
Miller wanted audiences to feel like
they're walking inside a comic book and
at that they succeeded based on the
actors the story the villains and their
faithfulness to the comics my conclusion
is that Tom Hollands is the best version
of spider-man
I'd say spider-man 2 is the absolute
best movie featuring spider-man into the
spider verse has the most unique story
and Andrew Garfield movies probably
can't even be measured on the same scale
but between the awesome suit the
formidable foe the actor and the
ultimately heartbreaking story arc we
are giving this one to Tom Holland and
the spider-man of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
do you agree with our choice who's your
favorite spider-man let us know in the
comments
[Music]